for more than 25 years Columbia has been
working to leave behind the violent
legacy of Pablo Escobar but there's one
unusual problem that keeps growing the
notorious drug lords pet hippos Manuel
Bojorquez reports along the shallow
water ways of Colombia's magdalena river
and invasive species threatens the
ecosystem and possibly a way of life
there are fishing villages that dot the
river and we've just bought it what
appears to be a hippo who is now trying
to hide from us Wow a brief glimpse of a
giant native only to Africa now running
wild in Colombia the story of the hippo
starts here the innopolis the former
estate of pablo escobar who in his
heyday had four hippo smuggled here for
his private Zoo Escobar's ranch housed
hundreds of exotic animals including
rhinos elephants and giraffes by the 80s
his cocaine Empire made him the
wealthiest and most feared drug lord in
the world for Colombia it was a reign of
terror he's said to be responsible for
some 7,000 deaths yo soy Pablo amigo
Escobar's guy Vidya still he's become
part of popular culture with shows like
Netflix's narcos in this scene Escobar's
character threatens to throw a rival
leader to the hippos around the time
Escobar met his death in the early 90s
the government relocated most of the
animals but not the hippos people forgot
the hippos forgot baby puss so the
hippos were then allowed to just roam
free yeah
and they had Mexico they had awesome
ring biologist David at Chevette he
works with Gore na'toth the
environmental agency in charge of
tracking and managing the hippos in the
region and how many are there now about
50 hippos are more more are more that
you know of there are 50 but you clearly
you're not gonna be able to see them all
yes because look at look at their own
[Music]
paradise because they have no predators
and ample food and water but they're
getting too close to people it's not
uncommon to spot a 3,000 pound hippo
walking around town locals call them the
village pets atcha vetti says they're
anything but the hippos are very
dangerous they're Poisson territorial
species so they will attack people yes
yes in Africa hippos cause more human
deaths than any other large animal so
far there are no known attacks in
Colombia the majority of the hippo still
live inside Escobar's former estate
which was turned into a theme park back
in 2007 the ma Attica okay I was gonna
play okay so he's saying we're getting
as close as we can to these hippos main
lake here because this mucho mucho queer
we have to be quick saligan del Lago see
core emotion in erectus quartz a bit of
a crash course and how to get close to
these creatures is not to get too close
of course he says they may come out of
the water to let us know we're on their
territory and if they charge run in a
zigzag motion because they can only run
in a straight line
[Music]
they're letting us know that they know
we're here
you can see all of those hippos behind
us here now the problem is they can't
keep them contained others have been
able to get out and that's how they're
turning up in other areas dos veces al
dsls try Senora abaca Paso picado is
Ellie's deposit uh you know sake so I
feel to try to keep them here
exactamente overdone Martinez runs the
theme park here the hippos are a main
attraction what we're seeing here is the
only pack of hippos in the wild outside
of Africa in estará here in Doral in
part a plasma semi rural urban MS
commune barely popota no cancer no it's
more common see a hippo here than a pig
in cerdo there's concern the hippos have
already started to displace native
wildlife like the threatened manatee and
keep getting too close for comfort
Jaime peso put the water in the past
year fisherman Pablo Jose Mejia has come
across five hippos that have ventured
outside the theme park so it's like a
dog as long as you know how to deal with
them you'll be okay but echeverria fears
with an ever-growing hippo population
it's only a matter of time until someone
gets hurt and killing the animals has
proven highly unpopular we can't just
kill him
the other solution is relegate if this
is a sterilizing HEPA sterilizing that
would be very difficult yes and it's
expensive expensive and very dangerous
but with limited funds it's a solution
unlikely to stem the tide on a legacy
that just keeps resurfacing for CBS this
morning Saturday and while parkas what
though three info Columbia suppose
they're surprisingly fast yes they are
yeah yeah I think I run straight but
they can yeah well let me tell you we
avoided them like the plague when I
lived in Kenya especially during the
rainy season